BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
MIHAI IONESCU: Hello.
Welcome to Google
Payments Live.
We have a very exciting session
today about one of the
coolest products at Google.
And our special guest is Robin
Dua, head of product
management for Google Wallet.
And of course, we're going
to talk about all the new
exciting developments around
Google Wallet.
So let's start with an
easy question, Robin.
What is Google Wallet?
ROBIN DUA: Great.
Well, first off, thanks for
having me here today.
Google Wallet is an electronic
wallet that allows you to
store all your credit cards,
debit cards, loyalty programs,
as well as offers that you've
clipped from different places,
all in one place that are easily
accessible through your
phone as well as online.
Users could access their Wallet
both online as well as
through their phone for
making purchases.
And it's also a great way for
users to be able to discover
great offers that they're
interested in and save money.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
So we recently announced
that we moved all
cards to the cloud.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about the technology
behind this transition?
ROBIN DUA: Sure.
Well, let me just start by
talking a little bit about the
momentum that has really
accelerated around the product
since we launched Google
Wallet back in
September of last year.
We started with one bank
partner, which was Citibank,
and we had one carrier
partner, Sprint.
And users were only able to use
a single device when we
launched, which was the
Nexus S device.
And since then, we now support
a total of six devices on two
carrier networks, both Virgin
Mobile as well as Sprint.
And there's 25 national
retailers that are showcasing
the full Google Wallet user
experience that combines
offers, payments, loyalty as
part of our single-tap user
experience that we created.
And what single-tap allows a
user to do is with one tap
they're able to transmit their
payment information, their
loyalty information, as well as
coupons that they're trying
to redeem, all with
a single action.
And these national retailers
have done a special
integration to create that
user experience in their
stores as part of the purchasing
experience.
We also have a total of about
200,000 locations where users
could actually tap their phone
and pay for things using
Google Wallet.
And that number is continuing to
increase month over month.
And we're excited by the fact
that retailers are continuing
to add contactless readers
to their point of sale.
And there'll be a lot more
places to use it.
In terms of the reference that
you made to our support for
all cards in the Wallet, we're
really excited by the
announcement we made at the
beginning of August where
Google Wallet now supports all
your credit and debit cards.
So you can link any Visa,
MasterCard, Amex, Discover
branded card to your Wallet
and use it not only for
in-store purchases using the
phone but use it online as
well at participating
retailers.
And the nice thing about Google
Wallet is the Wallet
could also be used for purchases
through Google
Properties as well, like the
Google store where you could
buy applications,
digital content.
You can also use it to buy
digital content through
YouTube as well as the Chrome
store and other
properties as well.
So Google Wallet is really
becoming the central way to
make purchases, not only on
Google Properties but in store
as well as online as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: Sounds
exciting.
How about a demo?
Can you show us how the
new Wallet works?
ROBIN DUA: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I'd be excited to show you
guys a new version of our
application that we launched
at the beginning of August.
PENG YING: Our producer, Louis,
has heroically given us
his Galaxy Nexus to play with.
ROBIN DUA: Great.
Well, let me just start on
the main screen here.
So what users are looking at
right now is the main screen
that you see when you go
into Google Wallet.
So there's four icons
on the main screen--
Payment Cards, Rewards Cards,
Offers, and Transactions.
So if I go into Payment Cards,
this is where I would see the
cards that I've added to Google
Wallet, either online
or through the application
itself.
And the nice thing about the
application is I could go in
and add cards any time if I
choose to add additional
credit or debit cards to
my Wallet application.
In addition to that, we've got
a prepaid card which is
available for users that want
a stored-value-based product
to transact with.
And here you could see all the
cards that are in the Wallet
that I'm demoing.
So there's an Amazon Visa.
There's a United Visa card.
I could also add additional
gift cards into
the Wallet as well.
So just going back to the main
screen for a second, I could
also discover offers from
participating merchants that I
might be interested in.
So here I could see offers
from Foot Locker.
There is some offers from
American Eagle, and other
nearby retailers as well.
PENG YING: Oh, my. $7
off large pizzas.
ROBIN DUA: That's right.
PENG YING: Where's that from?
ROBIN DUA: That one is actually
from Mario's Italiano.
MIHAI IONESCU: Sounds
delicious.
ROBIN DUA: That's only 1.7 miles
away, so maybe we could
get over there for
lunch after.
PENG YING: Early lunch.
MIHAI IONESCU: I'm getting
hungry already.
ROBIN DUA: That's right.
Exactly.
So you could see that there's a
lot of offers that are shown
here in the list.
And what we're trying to do is
increase the offers inventory
so that everybody could find
great deals from merchants
that they love.
And the other thing to just
highlight here is you could
see all the transactions that
you made using Google Wallet,
both online as well as in-store
transactions that you
made with the phone.
And if you click on one of
these transactions in the
history, it'll show you the name
of the retailer, the date
and time that you made the
transaction, the amount, the
payment method that you used
to make the transaction.
And if you've enabled it in the
application itself, it'll
also show you a map of where
you did the transaction.
And this is a great way for
people to see where they
actually did a transaction.
It kind of is a nice way to
jog their memory about a
particular retailer where they
transacted and they want to
remember where it was.
PENG YING: That's for those,
like, hazy bar nights, right?
You're like, oh, man--
ROBIN DUA: Exactly.
PENG YING: --where was I?
ROBIN DUA: For those bar nights
where you had a great
time and you want to figure out
where it was and you don't
really remember, you could go
into Google Wallet and see a
little map.
And it'll tell you how
to get there, so.
So those are some of the core
features of the Wallet
application.
So key things to highlight that
we did as part of the
August release-- one is
we now support all
cards in the Wallet.
PENG YING: Awesome.
ROBIN DUA: Two, we actually
enabled some additional
security features for users.
So users can now go online.
In the event that they lose
their phone, they could
actually disable Google Wallet
on their phone remotely.
And what this web-based feature
does is it also wipes
out any information that's
stored on your phone related
to your Wallet.
So there's added peace of
mind there for users.
And the third thing that we've
done is we've enhanced the
user interface to make it a
lot more user friendly.
And you could see that just
adding cards to the Wallet
could be done with just
a few clicks.
And we're really excited
about that.
PENG YING: OK.
That's pretty awesome.
So you previously talked about
the growth that we've
currently experienced and then
where we are right now.
But I guess everybody is
interested in where we go in
the future.
What are we doing to try to
drive growth, both in terms of
number of users of Wallet and
the number of merchants who
support Wallet?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
Well, the vision behind Wallet
is we want it to be an
electronic wallet that holds
all your payment cards,
loyalty cards, gift cards, but
also other types of digital
objects, things that you have in
your physical wallet today.
So things like identification,
as an example, or the transit
pass that you use every day,
also boarding passes, and
other forms of loyalty,
and so forth.
So what we're trying to do is
electronify all of these
things and make them easily
accessible through the phone,
but also available for online
purchases and interactions
online as well.
In terms of distribution, as I
mentioned earlier, we have six
devices that we support today.
We think NFC is going to become
a standard feature of
all smartphones over the
next little while.
And we're already starting
to see evidence
of that in the market.
And as a result of that, we
want Google Wallet to be
available on all devices
and all platforms.
And we want it to be the
preferred way that consumers
pay for things.
PENG YING: So what
about merchants?
How are we driving merchant
adoption?
Is it just because we're driving
user adoption and
merchants are like, uh-oh, OK,
there's more users so I should
just support it as well?
Or are we helping them
with point of sale or
anything like that?
Can you even get into
that at all?
ROBIN DUA: Yeah.
No.
Absolutely.
So one of the things that we've
done is we've actually
created single-tap, which allows
merchants to integrate
our technology into their
point-of-sale system to enable
this great one-tap user
experience that combines
offers, payments, loyalty into
a single interaction.
One of the things that we're
trying to do is actually
enable more cloud-based services
for retailers.
So things like being able to
enable delivery of coupons as
well as loyalty information
from the cloud back to the
point of sale.
And we're also enabling
cloud-based tools that allow
retailers to create customized
loyalty programs and targeted
offers campaigns and really get
a great set of analytics
that they can have access to
to know who their customers
are, how they're shopping at
their locations, and whether
the campaigns are effective in
terms of bringing users back
into their stores and increasing
the basket size of
their purchases.
So one of the things that we're
trying to do is really
make it easy not only for the
large retailer to use these
tools for offers and loyalty
programs, but we want to make
it accessible to small to
midsize retailers as well.
And so over the next little
while, you're going to see
Google Wallet create these new
cloud-based services that will
make couponing campaigns,
loyalty campaigns accessible
to all merchants.
PENG YING: So it seems like you
are trying to tie online
traffic with brick-and-mortar
store traffic, right?
That's the goal?
One of the goals.
ROBIN DUA: That's one
of the goals.
PENG YING: One of the goals.
ROBIN DUA: And if you look at
what we're trying to do
through the Wallet from a
consumer perspective, which is
helping them discover great
offers that they're interested
in and helping them connect with
merchants that they love.
On the merchant side, we're also
trying to make it easier
for them to connect with the
consumers that are shopping in
their stores and help them bring
those consumers back
into their stores.
PENG YING: Seems really useful
to be able to say, hey, why
don't you come back some time?
So now that we talked about
that a little bit, can you
kind of expand on the vision
of what we hope the Wallet
ecosystem will be?
What we hope to enable both
users of Wallet and any
additional features and
functionality for merchants of
Wallet to be able to offer?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
So, in terms of what we envision
Wallet becoming, we
want it to be a platform where
merchants could integrate
their loyalty programs and
offers campaigns easily into
Wallet and not have to do
extensive point-of-sale
integrations.
And what we're focused on is
making it super simple for
merchants to take advantage of
these programs, with either
doing no integration at all
and just leveraging their
existing card network processing
that they already
have in place.
And in some cases, just
providing light APIs that
would allow merchants to do
some of the things that I
talked about earlier.
And from the standpoint of other
partners, one of things
that we're trying to do is make
it easy for airlines,
transit providers, other types
of issuers of credentials,
make it super simple for them
to get their credentials
stored in the Wallet.
And then this is where we kind
of envision an open platform
where we will allow all sorts
of partners to be able to
issue their credentials into the
Wallet and allow users to
use them, not only with the
phone but also online as well.
PENG YING: Finally, I could
totally just throw away my
wallet-- except for
cash, I guess.
I could probably carry a money
clip around or something.
ROBIN DUA: That's the goal.
We want you to be able to leave
your leather wallet at
home and carry your phone and
transact with that as your
primary transaction device.
PENG YING: It totally
makes sense.
I don't think I leave the house
without my phone anyway
these days, so.
And then one last question--
now that you've talked about all
of these things that we're
trying to do, how can developers
interact with these
products that we're going
to deploy or that
we're going to launch?
ROBIN DUA: Well, so one of the
things that we've done is
we've launched a set of APIs for
specific partners today.
So we have APIs that allow
issuers, as an example, to
integrate to us and enable their
users to save a credit
or debit card from internet
banking or mobile banking
applications directly
to Google Wallet.
And we announced a partnership
with Discover back at Google
I/O, which was just
a few weeks ago.
And we have a bunch of other
card issuer partners that are
going to be announcing
the support for
those APIs very soon.
So users will be able to go into
their internet and mobile
banking applications to store
cards into Wallet.
One of the nice things that
we've done on that front is
issuers could actually provide
us with their card art so that
when a user saves a card into
the Wallet, the user actually
sees a great representation of
that physical card that they
have in their leather wallet
in the phone as well.
PENG YING: Cool.
ROBIN DUA: And we've also got
a set of APIs that we
announced at Google I/O that
allow merchants to integrate a
Save to Wallet button into their
email, as well as web
marketing campaigns that
they're doing.
So a user would see the Save to
Wallet button and be able
to clip a coupon
electronically to their Wallet.
And that coupon would be
available through the
application on their phone.
And with our single-tap
technology, the coupon could
be used there or using a show
and scan type experience.
So those are just two examples
of the types of APIs we have
available today.
And we're working hard to create
a set of APIs that'll
allow other types of partners
integrate into Wallet and take
advantage of storing credentials
to the Wallet, but
also other features as well.
PENG YING: So if a developer
wanted to get started with
implementing some of these APIs
today, where would they
go to find out more
information?
ROBIN DUA: Well, we've
got a partner
website set up for issuers.
So there's a dedicated site for
that where card issuers
could learn more about the APIs
and sign up on the site.
There's also a dedicated site
for merchants, as well, which
is available.
And then provides all sorts of
information about how to get
access to the Save to Wallet
button and the APIs and how to
integrate it into their
marketing campaigns online.
And it's super simple
to integrate these
APIs, by the way.
It's just really a matter of
days and in some cases, hours.
It's not a lot of work.
PENG YING: Yeah.
We try to simplify as
much as we can.
So that site's
google.com/payments, I believe?
ROBIN DUA: Yeah.
If you go to google.com/wallet,
this is a
consumer site.
But you can actually access
some of the partner sites
through there as well.
PENG YING: Got it.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we get a lot
of questions from developers
and merchants about adoption.
And along those lines, can you
talk a little bit about NFC
adoption and second,
about availability
on additional carriers?
ROBIN DUA: Sure.
Great question.
When we first launched, we had
one device that supported
Google Wallet.
And we're up to six phones today
on two carrier networks,
Virgin as well as Sprint.
And we're looking to expand
our carrier distribution.
We're in discussions today
with a number of other
carriers and hope to make some
announcements over the next
little while.
So stay tuned for that.
Just on the device question, we
are going to see NFC become
a standard feature of every
smartphone device.
This is a trend that is
taking place today.
Actually, a very good indication
of that is the
Galaxy S3, which launched
a little while ago.
It sold 10 million devices
in the first two months.
And this was a flagship device
of Samsung's and has NFC as a
core feature in there.
And what's driving the NFC
adoption in phones is not just
the payments-use cases, but it's
also use cases like being
able to share content between
devices as well as pairing,
say, a handset as well as a set
of speakers or headphones
to the device as well.
So there's a lot more
applications for NFC.
And you will see NFC become
a core feature just like
cameras, Bluetooth, Wi-Fi,
things that we kind of take
for granted today.
Yeah, who thought a few years
ago that cameras would be in
every smartphone?
So NFC is going to take the
same position in terms of
being a core feature
in devices.
So that is actually
going to drive
adoption of Google Wallet.
And we're quite excited about
the trends that we're seeing
in the market.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Fantastic.
Another question we get from
a lot of our developers, in
particular international
developers--
we have plans to go
internationally and what's
stopping us?
Why the delay on making
this available
outside the United States?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
Well, great question.
We obviously wanted to get
Google Wallet perfected and
working here in the US.
We're a global company.
We certainly have an interest
in bringing Google Wallet to
other markets overseas.
And what I can tell you is we
are actively planning the
roll-out of Google Wallet
in other markets.
So stay tuned for some
announcements there.
I don't have anything to share
at this point, but we are
actively pushing hard
to bring Google
Wallet to other markets.
PENG YING: So next year?
Next two years?
ROBIN DUA: Stay tuned.
Stay tuned.
PENG YING: All right.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll keep
people updated.
We have shows every
couple of weeks.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll
let you know.
ROBIN DUA: That's right.
Exactly.
You could have me back
on another show.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll
definitely--
PENG YING: Next time, yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: --do
that, I guess.
Let's talk a little bit about
other merchant-led
initiatives, like the
MCX initiative.
If you want to talk a little
bit about it or other
wallet-related products.
ROBIN DUA: Sure.
So this is actually a really
good point that there's going
to be a lot of wallets
out there over
the next little while.
And we actually think it's a
great thing for there to be
lots of competition because it
actually makes the product
better at the end of the day.
It forces everybody to really
think through what are the
user experiences that
people want.
And it forces everybody to build
better products at the
end of the day.
It also helps on two
other fronts.
One is those wallets out there
that are taking an approach to
use NFC technology in the phone
are actually going to
encourage retailers to install
contactless readers into their
point-of-sale system.
So this will actually result
in much greater interest on
the part of retailers
to upgrade
point-of-sale terminals.
And the other effect that it
has is on the device side.
I think OEMs are already
motivated by the exciting use
cases that NFC offers.
But with more wallet providers
out there and consumers having
a choice, I think OEMs will be
much more motivated to put NFC
into their devices.
So all of these things will
actually result in increased
momentum around mobile payments
in the market, which
I think is a great thing
for Google as well.
The other thing I just want
to highlight is from the
standpoint of differentiation.
We've adopted a new approach
as part of our
recent Wallet release.
We've moved the Wallet
to the cloud.
And all a user's payment
credentials are now stored
securely on servers
in the cloud.
And what this offers users the
ability to do is access their
Wallet through any device
and through any channel.
And under the old model that
we had, we were actually
integrating with each
card issuer.
And this integration, from the
time of negotiation to
integration, would take
anywhere from
six months to a year.
And under this model, the
cards were stored in the
secure element in
the NFC device.
We just didn't feel that this
model was very scalable.
It would literally take a
lifetime to get through the
8,500 or so issuers that
are in the US.
And so by adopting this
cloud-based approach, we
greatly simplified not only the
user experience because
now I could have a wallet with
all my cards and other
credentials made available to
me through any channel.
But it also gives me a lot of
flexibility to transact in
ways that I didn't have the
opportunity to before.
But also on the issuer side,
issuers are excited about the
new cloud-based approach because
the time to market for
them in terms of enabling their
cards to work with NFC
has been reduced
to almost zero.
And in some cases, issuers could
say, I don't want to do
any integration.
I'm happy just providing you
with card art and having my
card represented in
the Wallet so that
consumers see my brand.
But we also have a set of tools
and APIs that issuers
could integrate if they want
to enable features like
enabling their users to save
cards to the Wallet directly
from internet banking or
mobile banking sites.
And that's a really lightweight
integration that
doesn't take six months
to a year.
It actually just takes a matter
of days or a few weeks
at the most.
So I think this is actually
a really important point.
Because there are a lot of
wallet providers out there
that are stuck on this approach
of let's integrate
with every issuer and let's
enable this over the year,
provisioning of cards to
the secure element.
And it's just not a
scalable approach.
And it's not going to give
consumers access to every one
of their cards that they have
in their leather wallet in
their phone.
PENG YING: So we're trying
to simplify it as much as
possible for everybody.
ROBIN DUA: Exactly.
PENG YING: Ideally, it's one
click, add my card to Wallet,
and then you're done.
ROBIN DUA: That's it.
That's it.
And we wanted to make the Wallet
user experience, from
the time of enrollment to
using it, super simple.
And I think we've done that.
PENG YING: Nice.
Nice.
So it looks like-- wow.
MIHAI IONESCU: Well,
we have so many
questions on the moderator.
I was watching it while
you were talking.
And I see hundreds of people,
thousands of votes.
So I think we answered and
touched on a lot of the topics
in the questions here.
I'll go through a few of them
and if you can do a brief
recap of what we said.
And then I'll try to
pick a few that
haven't been answered.
So of course, one of the
big ones is adoption.
NFC payments seemed to be
limited to gas stations,
general stores, and some few
other stores out there.
What are we doing to encourage
merchants and other companies
and vendors to adopt
Google Wallet?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
So historically, what we've
seen over the last little
while is large merchants have
typically been the ones to
adopt new point-of-sale
technology.
And this has been applicable
to contactless as well.
So you've seen the large
retailers integrate
contactless into their
point of sale.
And now what we're starting
to see is that trend--
or contactless adoption-- is
moving down market into small
to midsize retailers.
And the card networks, as well
as merchant acquirers, are
certainly pushing to get
contactless readers into those
small to midsize retailers.
Now from a Google perspective,
we're creating some
cloud-based tools that'll make
it easy for small to midsize
merchants to create loyalty and
coupon programs in a very
inexpensive way and a very
cost-effective way that they
haven't had access to before.
And all of those services work
in conjunction with the
contactless user experience
with the phone.
So I think that, plus the fact
that the cost on the readers
is actually going down quite
significantly, we're going to
see greater penetration of NFC
into much smaller retailers
over the next little while.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
PENG YING: And right now, it's
any retailer that accepts
PayPass, right, that accepts
the MasterCard PayPass, can
accept Google Wallet
for a tap and pay?
ROBIN DUA: That's right.
That's exactly it.
There's about 200,000 merchant
locations in the US that have
contactless readers where you
can use Google Wallet.
Now, one thing to highlight is
all of these readers also
accept card-based payments
with contactless.
So what we're trying to do is
actually piggyback off of the
existing infrastructure that
retailers already have to
enable payments using
Google Wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: A very popular
question on the moderator is,
when will we be able
to pay other
individuals with Google Wallet?
ROBIN DUA: Well, that's
a great question.
And from our standpoint, we want
to create a wallet that
actually allows you to leave
your leather wallet at home.
And we've started with payment
cards, loyalty
cards, and gift cards.
We're focused on getting
other types of
credentials into the Wallet.
So that's one thing
that we're doing.
On the question of cash, a
wallet wouldn't be fully
functional if it also didn't
allow users to manage their
currency and transact not only
with businesses, but also with
end users as well.
So these are some things
that we're looking at.
And from our perspective,
we recognize
that there is a need.
And stay tuned for some
announcements there over the
next little while.
PENG YING: Stay tuned.
So then I don't even
need my money clip.
I can just carry around
the phone.
But what happens if that phone
runs out of power?
ROBIN DUA: Well.
PENG YING: That's a
tough question.
ROBIN DUA: That is
a tough question.
Battery life is getting
better.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's
for another session.
PENG YING: Save that
one for next time.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
We'll save it.
ROBIN DUA: Yeah, exactly.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we have a
question here for someone who
is both a developer
and a merchant.
He uses Google Wallet on his
website to charge users but
wants to take Wallet payments
from customers at local fairs.
So he's selling stuff at local
fairs or the farmers market.
Was that possible?
Would that be possible?
Is that possible?
ROBIN DUA: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So if the individual has a
point-of-sale terminal, they
could actually get a contactless
reader, which
would allow them to accept
contactless payments using
cards, but also Google Wallet
payments using an NFC device.
And there's a lot of contactless
readers that are
already built into point-of-sale
terminals.
Some of the newer ones, it's
all fully integrated.
But the individual
could also get a
standalone contactless reader.
Just plug it into a
point-of-sale terminal that
they have for credit
card transactions.
PENG YING: Right.
I got a question here.
So let's say that I'm not on one
of the supported networks.
Is there anyway for
me to use wallets?
The question here is, I'm still
unable to get Google
Wallet on my Verizon
Galaxy Nexus.
Will that change now that FCC
has made it clear that Verizon
has no right to block
applications,
ie, tethering apps?
And why is there no other
way to download?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
So we have two carrier partners
today, Virgin and Sprint.
And all the NFC devices
that we support
work on those networks.
Now, there are a handful of NFC
devices that you could go
out and buy at places
like Best Buy.
These are devices that
would be unlocked.
And you can actually use them
on the other networks and
download Google Wallet from the
Play store and use Google
Wallet that way.
We are working on expanding
our carrier distribution.
And we are actively in
negotiations with a number of
other carriers and hope to
announce some partnerships
there soon.
That will also give users
the ability to use
Wallet on other networks.
PENG YING: Got it.
Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: We have a
question about the Isis
technology.
Do we have anything?
PENG YING: What's
the question?
MIHAI IONESCU: The question
is, do you plan on
integrating, partnering with the
Isis technology that the
wireless carriers
are supporting?
ROBIN DUA: Well, Isis
has a very different
approach than we do.
I talked a little bit about the
differentiator between our
cloud-based approach and the
approach where a number of
other wallet providers, and Isis
included, are working on
direct provisioning of cards
from an issuer to the secure
element, in their case,
the SIM in the phone.
We just don't think that model
is scalable for the simple
reason that, as I mentioned
earlier, there's 8,500
issuers in the US.
And it literally will take them
a lifetime to actually
work through negotiations
with all these issuers.
And keep in mind, it's not just
about getting payment
cards into the phone.
People want a wallet that works
with loyalty, with gift
cards, with identification,
boarding passes, with all
these other credential types.
And we think what we've done
is made it super simple for
you to store any of
these digital
objects into the Wallet.
We obviously don't have support
for all of them today,
but we're working
towards that.
And we just think the
cloud-based approach that
we've adopted is better for the
end user, but also better
for partners.
PENG YING: I have another one.
I want to use Google Wallet to
pay for bus and train rides.
Will Google be working with
Metro to have this become a
possibility?
ROBIN DUA: So transit is a
really important use case.
And people ride transit
systems daily,
multiple times a day.
And there's a great opportunity
here to simplify
the payment experience because
I've always got my phone in my
pocket or on my waist.
And just taking it out and
tapping is a great way to
simplify the user experience so
I don't have to fumble and
find my card in my wallet.
But also, there's an added
benefit which is buying a pass
through the Wallet becomes
a lot easier.
I don't have to go to the local
convenience store or
stand in line at the metro
station to actually buy a pass
every month.
I could actually do that through
the Wallet over the
next little while.
I could also see--
if it's a stored value type of
pass, I could see the balance
on the pass.
So these are some of
the reasons why
transit is really important.
And we're certainly working
towards getting transit passes
into the Wallet as well.
PENG YING: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: I have a question
about someone who
wants to use the ATM
with the Wallet.
Can we add ATM cards
to the Wallet?
And have we talked with any
ATM manufacturers to use
Wallet on ATM machines?
ROBIN DUA: There's been some
discussion about ATM
manufacturers integrating
contactless or NFC technology
into the ATMs.
We think it's probably a
little bit further out.
It's not something that we're
focused on at this point.
PENG YING: So this guy
has a suggestion.
But I think we cover the cases
already right now, but I'm not
quite sure.
So the question is, I'd like
to integrate location-based
awareness to Wallet and
adding retailers.
When I go to Starbucks, I
want my card to pop up
and Wallet to pay.
When I go to movie theater,
I'd like my AMC card to be
integrated so I can
pay with Wallet.
I feel like we would pass both
if they're already integrated
with our APIs, right?
ROBIN DUA: Yeah.
I think what the user's
referring to is how can we
simplify the user experience so
that maybe the relevant set
of gift cards or coupons
actually pop up when I'm in
that store or in the vicinity
of that store.
Location-based services using
geo-fencing or GPS technology
is something that we're
actively looking at.
And we're always working towards
simplifying the user
experience so that you don't
have to do things with as many
clicks on the phone.
So, you won't have to, as an
example, go in, find the
Wallet application, launch
it, and then go
into the right tab.
It would automatically pop up on
the main screen when you're
in that store.
So these are some of the things
that we're looking to
simplify in terms of
user experience.
And you'll start to see
enhancements to the product
over the next little while
that'll take advantage of
location-based services.
PENG YING: Cool.
Let's do two more questions
and then--
MIHAI IONESCU: Two
more question--
PENG YING: --call it a day.
MIHAI IONESCU: --and yeah, we're
running out of time.
So we got quite a few questions
about loyalty cards
and the discount programs.
I know you touched on it
a little bit earlier.
Can you summarize what we're
doing along those lines and
make it easier for both
merchants and users to very
easily use all kind of coupons
and loyalty points?
ROBIN DUA: Right.
So I talked a little bit about
the Save to Wallet button that
we launched at Google I/O, which
allows a user to save
offers to their Wallet.
And we also enabled the Save to
Wallet button to work for
issuer cards directly through
internet banking, as well as
mobile banking applications.
You could imagine a whole
ecosystem being built around
that Save to Wallet button.
So it becomes a lot easier
when you are on a partner
website and you want to actually
save, whether it's a
boarding pass or a loyalty
card or a gift
card, to the Wallet.
And we're looking at opening
those APIs to other partners
so that things like loyalty
cards, like you mentioned,
will become easier to be
saved to the Wallet.
The other thing that we're
doing just on the loyalty
front is we want to make it
really easy for retailers to
create their own loyalty
programs using
tools that we offer.
So we're looking to create
some cloud-based services
that'll allow small merchants,
but also the largest
retailers, to actually take
advantage of tools to
customize loyalty programs so
that they don't have to invest
in software and point-of-sale
infrastructure to enable
loyalty programs.
PENG YING: There you go.
MIHAI IONESCU: One more.
PENG YING: And then last one.
You know, I've read a few
stories with events kind of
similar to this, but this
one's a good one.
I've been to McDonald's and
I tried to pay with Google
Wallet three times.
It's only worked once.
Are there any issues
with stability?
Or what are we doing to
make it more stable?
ROBIN DUA: There are some retail
locations where there
may be some issues with the
contactless reader.
We would encourage the user to
report those issues to the
retailer themselves so they
could actually address those
reader issues.
Users could also log
an issue through
the application itself.
We've got a section in the
application, in the help
section, where users could
report issues that they're
encountering related to these
types of reader issues.
We're working with merchants,
the card networks, acquirers
to address proactively
any reader
issues that are surfaced.
We are looking for ways to
implement more automated
technology to detect reader
issues with some of our
partners and trying to address
these problems much, much
faster so that users don't
encounter issues like that.
PENG YING: Got it.
ROBIN DUA: All right.
MIHAI IONESCU: Good.
PENG YING: And with that.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we'll
wrap up here.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
And of course, thanks, Robin,
for graciously agreeing to
come on the session.
Remember, this is available
on Google
Developers channel on YouTube.
You can watch it anytime
you want.
We have sessions every
two weeks.
And we hope to see Robin again
soon on a another session.
ROBIN DUA: Well, thanks very
much for having me, guys.
And to all of you watching, go
to google.com/wallet and sign
up for a Wallet account there.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
OK.
PENG YING: See you
in two weeks.
MIHAI IONESCU: See
you in two weeks.
Bye.